[Music]
state news now or nextar Media Group I
will tell them to us off
if they do that again
tonight on politics now how a bickering
School Board is costing you tax dollars
it was my obligation on behalf of the
voters
Clark County Commissioner Justin Jones
up for re-election and accused of
corruption he talks about his votes on a
controversial Red Rock Housing
Development and his vision for the
future plus no endorsement Clark
County's largest teachers union chooses
to stay out of the hotly contested
Governor's rates
[Music]
from 8 news now this is politics now
thank you very much for joining us here
on politics now I'm John langler we
start with Clark County School District
their elected leaders responsible for
the direction of CCSD but watching a
meeting can seem like more of a reality
show instead of government constant
arguments are visible in person and on
social media as a right news now
investigator David charns found out it's
costing you money
I'm gonna go tweet about it hypocrite
she's just gonna tweet about it
okay so they're public moments
highlighting a school board in chaos
thank you afford for the offer how about
you put that on your campaign website
okay trustees we are not doing this
absolutely not uh we will shut down the
lines if you two cannot communicate
professionally infighting among the
Clark County School Board of Trustees
seen in full View and posted online what
can I do to help you
um improve your social media habits
because it's taking this entire
organization and the group dynamics but
the seven trustees have tried to get
along at least through trainings costing
Clark County taxpayers thousands the
eighties now investigators filing public
records requests with CCSD to find out
how much invoices revealing at least
four sessions cost to combined fifteen
thousand dollars the biggest charge 8
500 to learn quote skills and strategies
work better as a board and help
individual trustees meet their
individual needs
this was trustee Katie Williams just
last week this board is absolutely
insane it's it's completely off the
rails and do you think that any
superintendent worth his weight in gold
or her weight in gold right uh is gonna
want to come to this District after we
have
constantly put ourselves on display I
think my interaction is just fine in
fact that's what I was voted for trustee
Daniel Ford is often the most outspoken
this tweet from May directed to trustee
Williams saying shut the expletive up
this was a meeting in June I will tell
them to f off
if they do that again I will absolutely
go on social media where I know that
anybody could see it if they wanted to
and speak the truth about what happened
or set the record straight Ford says the
district is spending even more money on
training sessions she says are not
beneficial she tells us she'd rather sit
and learn about policy and law we don't
get any training on that all of our
training is just be quiet why are you
being rude you should be nice to the
other members of the board
there's a road map now in front of you
that you can choose to move forward on
in May the board talked about the
policies it paid to develop notes and
recommendations include not to post
individually on social media and instead
quote speaking with one voice to send a
clear message on the priorities and
progress of District goals there are
many issues that we have interpersonally
with each other we fail to constantly
address them or we address them
ineffectively with fifteen thousand
dollars spent on the sessions we found
invoices for
this was board president Irene cepeda's
response just this past summer it is
insane that I spent so much time
disciplining trustees
one that is shouldn't not be the case
and that was David Charles reporting
CCSD elections are nonpartisan three
trustees are up for re-election this
November including board president Irene
Cepeda and the woman you heard from
trustee Danielle Ford Nevada's largest
teachers union is staying out of the
governor's race this week the Clark
County Education Association announced
it's not going to endorse a candidate
for the November election back in 2018
the organization did endorse and
campaigned for current Democratic
governor Steve sisalak however now the
ccea says Governor sisalak hasn't
outlined a plan to address issues like
Rising class sizes in campus violence
the union is also not endorsing
Republican Challenger Joe Lombardo in a
statement sizzleak's campaign says his
government has given teachers their
first raise in more than a decade the
campaign also touted a deal the
sister-like administration brokered with
mining companies to send 500 million
dollars new tax dollars towards
education
a large gun control political action
committee is spending millions of
dollars in that tight Nevada governor's
race every town for govern safety plans
to put 3.6 million dollars on ads
attacking Joe Lombardo the ads you're
seeing right here feature people the
group says are Nevada voters talking
about violence in their communities
during Lombardo's time as Sheriff
Lombardo's campaign blames Governor
sisalak's crime policies as being too
soft and too restrictive on police
governor sisalaka and State Senate
Majority Leader Nicole cannizzaro touted
Nevada's Healthcare public option this
week the Democrats estimate this will
help another 350 000 nevadans get
insurance it was passed in the last
legislative session and works to
establish a state managed public health
insurance option by 2026.
is going to make the option available
for more people that previously wouldn't
have had it available to them we're
expecting over 50 000 in the first year
the Republican campaign the Republican
opponent rather Joe Lombardo his
campaign released a statement saying in
part this just puts additional mandates
on insurance companies that'll force
them to cost shift and raise rates on
people all across Nevada
Democratic State Treasurer Zach konine
has filed another election complaint
against his opponent in the upcoming
election Republican Michelle Fiore the
complaint was filed with the Secretary
of State's office co9 accuses Fiore of
taking donations over the ten thousand
dollar limit and using fake donor names
co9 adds he'll give information that he
has found to law enforcement in response
Fiore's campaign says quote conine is
using a minor clerical error to smoke
screen his deliberate Act of divesting
from companies because he disagrees with
the Constitution and invests in the
Communist Party of china-owned companies
instead
now to the race for Clark County
Commission in District F incumbent
Democrat Justin Jones faces Republican
Challenger Drew Johnson now last week we
heard from Johnson this week we spoke
with commissioner Jones
what does District F your District need
that hasn't been achieved in the last
four years well you know it's been an
interesting four years John we had a lot
of goals for district F and for the
county more generally and then covet hit
us and so we had to really focus all of
our attention on making sure that we
protected People's Health and well-being
and did everything we could in order to
re reinvigorate the economy and so
that's what we did we spent a lot of
time and effort on covid and you've seen
the economy come roaring back we we
spend a lot of time and effort and and
frankly money in supporting small
business owners your opponent also
suggests that broadly in Clark County
there's a lot of money being wasted
there isn't enough of watching of the
money being spent keeping an eye on
where the taxpayers money is going are
you confident that the contracts that
are assigned this is kind of a broad
question I realized but do you think
that the taxpayers are being well served
by you and the other Commissioners with
their money I think absolutely our CFO
is one of the frankly most conservative
CFOs out there pre-pandemic we were in
the strongest financial situation of any
local jurisdiction and we continue to be
so there's a reason why our bond ratings
are at the top of every jurisdiction in
the state of Nevada we are fiscally
conservative we make sure that we spend
every dollar in the right way and if any
issues come up we go audit those those
expenditures and we've clawed back money
when we found that there were issues out
there even from nonprofits one of uh an
issue that you have close to your heart
is the issue of Red Rock and protection
of Red Rock both uh as County
Commissioner and beforehand as well talk
about some of the efforts that you have
taken to try and protect Red Rock but
also increase access to it sure
absolutely um as as a lot of the viewers
might know there's been a big battle
between a developer and Clark County
over the last 20 years the original
proposal from the developer was for more
than 5 000 homes and the the County
Commission uh in 2019 had denied the
request from the developer to waive a
condition that related to the road the
developer finally after 20 years came in
with a proposal that was within the
density that was permitted up there when
he bought it and so that was the subject
of a recent vote on the County
Commission well it's also the subject of
litigation that you're involved in as
well your opponent is accusing you of
being corrupt there's allegations of
conflict of interest that you voted on
this even though before you were on the
commission your previous as an attorney
you were involved in this case
allegations of Records being deleted
public records being deleted how do you
respond to these accusations well sure I
think I've responded publicly to these
accusations before with regards to to
the vote and the allegations that I was
conflicted out that's why I firmatively
went to the Nevada Commission on ethics
laid everything out to them before that
a vote and they said that I was required
to disclose my prior affiliation with uh
with a non-profit say Red Rock but but
that I was not only allowed to vote but
that was my obligation on behalf of the
voters who elected me
you can watch more of our interview with
Mr Jones the commissioner and our
interview with his opponent Drew Johnson
on 8newsnow.com
next on politics now more from the
County Commission races coming up
that point what the county should have
done and what the state should have done
is they should have file the federal
lawsuit against California for breach of
contract Republican Billy Mitchell
taking on commission chair Jim Gibson
we'll talk about his plan to tap
Toyota Let's Go Places
welcome back to politics now
this week the Las Vegas Asian Chamber of
Commerce has made its political
endorsements known it's a mix of
Republicans and Democrats the main ones
well for governor they endorsed
Republican Joe Lombardo lieutenant
governor as you see on your screen as
Republican Stavros Anthony the Asian
chamber though also picked two Democrats
Zach conine for treasurer and Cisco
Aguilar for Secretary of State
Billy Mitchell hopes to be the first
Republican on the Clark County
Commission in nearly two decades he's
running running against incumbent
Democrat and commission chair Jim Gibson
in District G that covers Southeast
areas of Clark County including
Henderson and Boulder City this week I
talked with him about what he would
change
that you've never run for a political
office before what motivated you to run
and for the viewers at home for the
voters at home uh some of your
background
so um I'm a veteran I was the ex-school
teacher I raced NASCAR I built found
Bellagio a lot of different engineering
projects I'm an engineering project
manager
um I just got to a point where I just
couldn't sit back anymore you know I
defended two Wars and this isn't the
country I remember growing up so I felt
like I needed to get involved and at
county level seems to be the appropriate
place so what is it at the county level
that you would want to address first
uh we need to do an audit and we need to
go through and be more accountable for
the money that's being spent and what
projects I'm working for DOD now I'm
very familiar with government processes
and from what I've seen at the County
Commission meetings they're not being
followed
explain a little bit about that what do
you mean specifically that's not being
followed give me an example of something
that stands out to you that you would
like to deal with right away
so the first thing that came to me was I
was at the water commissioning meeting a
couple weeks ago
and they just gave him 7.1 million
dollars right off the cuff
um the way I'm used to dealing with the
Department of Defense is you have to put
out rfps you have to do a bidding
process and you have to justify that
financing before you can just say
spend 7.1 million dollars on you know
digitizing records or whatever the
excuse here we're giving them so you
you're uh you think that sort of there's
a blank check at the County Commission
that you want to try and deal with what
do you think needs to be done from a
Clark County commission level to help
with our water shortages our water
issues and what's happening at Lake Mead
so I think the federal government means
to get involved and I think that our
County Commissioners and our County
needs to facilitate that that pact that
they have or agreement was from 1920s
they got to a two-way level just a few
weeks ago when the County Commission was
up there the reality is that you know
based off the information that the
Southern Nevada Water Authority
presented to the county that we're not
using any more water now than we did 10
years ago so why is the lake going dry
well it's real simple California is
using way over their allotment when they
got to a 2A which is a tier one level
they were all supposed to come to the
together and come back with cutbacks we
did that a matter of fact I call them
the Gibson mandates now with the pools
and the front yards that they just put
in
um
California didn't even come to the table
so at that point what the county should
have done and what the state should have
done is they should have filed a federal
lawsuit against California for breach of
contract and at that point it would have
forced them to come to the table before
it gets down to a 2B level which the
Southern Nevada Water Authority said is
going to be in less than 24 months and
they may have to shut the dam down what
do you think District G needs that the
incumbent is not providing so he he
doesn't even represent District G I've
had the police department the fire
departments all come to me the people in
in Boulder City
um he's a career politician when he left
Henderson he left him with a 90 Min
million dollar deficit that left
everybody with the bad taste in their
mouth when he first got appointed
to county commissioner
he shouldn't have he wasn't elected he
shouldn't he lost the mayor race he
didn't even get through the primary with
Dina Titus he should have just said
that's the end of politics but he didn't
he decided to throw his hat in the ring
at County Commissioner and I don't think
he's really represented Henderson or or
volder city well at all
we have the full interview on
eightnewsnow.com commissioner Gibson
meanwhile has not responded to our
requests for an interview
some good news for Nevada's state budget
the state collected a little more than a
billion dollars more in tax revenue over
the last year than expected during the
economic Forum this week analysts said
the state collected 5.5 billion dollars
led by Gaming taxes being up by about a
quarter of a billion dollars about 400
million dollars of that money is going
into the state's rainy day fund
Clark County has announced a new program
to help thousands of people who are
facing evictions the number of eviction
cases this year here in southern Nevada
has increased by about 50 percent up to
forty five thousand so far this new
diversion program is aimed at keeping
some of those people in their homes and
giving Social Services time to provide
resources to those families it'll cost a
little more than a million dollars
what's next for so-called dreamers next
on politics now how the Supreme Court
could rule on DACA and the new push to
keep the program alive through
legislation plus which Nevada House
races are among the most expensive in
the country
down
you're watching politics now
well Nevada has two of the most
expensive house races in the country
right now ad impact reports 27 million
dollars has been spent in the
Congressional District 3 race that's
between Democrat incumbent Susie Lee and
her Republican Challenger April Becker
that's actually tied for the most the
race for congressional district one
between Democratic incumbent Dina Titus
and Republican childra Mark Robertson
has tied for 10th 17 million dollars is
spent so far overall Nevada House races
have the third most money spent of any
state 55 million dollars they're ahead
of several states that actually have
more races
former president Trump plans to respond
to a subpoena from the house January 6th
committee all nine members of the
committee voted this week to hear Mr
Trump's testimony at a public hearing
the former president asked on social
media rhetorically why he wasn't allowed
to testify or ask to testify months ago
this week lawmakers presented new
evidence they say shows the Secret
Service were aware of threats made to
Capitol Hill before the actual attack a
final report from that house committee
is expected by the end of the year
a federal appeals court has ruled the
deferred action for childhood arrivals
program DACA is unlawful Washington D.C
correspondent Alexander Limon spoke with
a DACA recipient about the uncertainty
these young immigrants now face
I'm scared I'm I'm terrified Jaime
Rangel arrived in the U.S as an infant
he grew up and has made a life in
Northwest Georgia he's the Georgia state
immigration director for ford.us and now
I have a two-year-old son and I have a
wife I have a family but Rangel is
constantly living in fear that DACA a
program which allows him to stay at work
in the U.S could end this week the fifth
Circuit Court of Appeals ruled that DACA
is unlawful it was devastating because
the first thing first thing that came to
my mind is what's going to happen to our
family the court said current DACA
recipients can renew their school and
work permits for now it's heading to a
very terrible ending debugandi senior
director for immigration policy at the
center for American progress agrees
there's absolutely a chance that DACA
could be ended this case could end up
before the U.S Supreme Court and Gandhi
says previous rulings from the high
court signal the just businesses could
decide to end Docker often rule against
programs or rights that Americans
believe to be to be to be lawful this is
a call to action we need Republicans and
Democrats to get together do what
they're being paid to do legislate
rankel says only congressional action
will deliver permanent protections for
young immigrants like him who face
possible deportations in Washington
Alexandra Limon
right now there is no vote scheduled in
Congress to try and make DACA a
permanent program more politics news
not be our attorney general
foreign
[Music]
welcome back you can now apply for a
license to host public cannabis lounges
the application process for the state of
Nevada is open and business owners have
until the 27th to apply online the
Nevada cannabis compliance board set
State rules and regulations back in June
for those lounges the application fee is
ten thousand dollars it's non-refundable
only 20 applications will be chosen in
this Lottery process it's taking a long
time to get to this point
[Music]
this week in what to watch it's time to
start voting mail ballots have already
started going out to all registered
voters here in Clark County so you
should be getting one in the next few
days check your mailbox early voting
opens next Saturday the 22nd of October
you don't have to go to a specific
location you can vote at any early
voting spot you can also register to
vote on election day as well
that'll do it for us here on politics
now thank you so much for watching us
you can stay up to date online for all
the political news
8newsnow.com back with you next Saturday
take care thanks for watching
foreign
[Music]